tous les déchets qu'on jette dans le lac
ou dans la rivière viennent échouer ici
[Musique]
nous avons quatre groupes installés donc
là nous avons trois groupes qui sont en
service et le groupe est numéro 2 est à
l'arrêt c'est un groupe de 6,3 mégawatts
et donc sur le total de 30 mégawatts que
nous pouvons produire vous comprenez que
6,3 n'est pas disponible
[Musique]
et calzia l'auto show which unacois
nallo panda
rezaï
ont mal être est assez vrai tour à
souffrir et san
ku après le pit a dessiné la auto show
which have my classique ou en votant oui
car on a tout dérangé
kutiman ouvert aux coupes à tottenham et
au bout du problème
[Musique]
non
nous faisons vraiment de notre mieux
pour dépolluer les lacs une faisant même
du mieux pour éviter que les déchets
parviennent au lac donc il ya certaines
certains ménages qui nous appellent
aujourd'hui pour aller prendre leurs
déchets plastiques au niveau de leur
domicile
si nous faisons des campagnes des
ramassages parfois de dans les rivières
sur la route
[Musique]
où